well obviously at this very moment in
history the forces of our religion I
mean I'm among the forces is religion it
gives you some idea of how loony it is
to predict the future if if you had
asked me in say 1960 what's the future
of religion in the United States or in
the world I mean in its influence not
just i but practically anybody you ask
would have said it's dissipating it's
it's in all religions not just Islam
which we did which we knew nothing about
really but in say Christianity I mean
who would think that that that the
Republican presidential contenders would
have to pay court to somebody like Pat
Robertson who with Jerry Falwell agreed
that 911 took place because God lowered
his defensive shield on the United
States when he saw what was happening
with people from the American Way and
lesbianism and stuff like that I mean
there are any mullis black e'er than
that and and who would think that that
that Orthodox Judaism what would be the
force it is now I mean it seemed to be
disappearing really and and so obviously
you can't tell what's going to happen
and and religion certainly one of the
things is shape the situation we're in
now
you